there's a certain contradiction in the
idea of going for a relaxing bike ride
in the Indian mega city of Mumbai
according to the world health
organization somebody dies on India's
roads every five minutes getting around
by bike is not for the faint-hearted the
practicality of cycling in the city and
especially on these roads are not hiking
tracks no facilities available no stops
no holes no medical first aid no you
know organized infrastructure so that's
why people are a little afraid to take
the risk yet these great commuters have
decided to trade their cars for a bike I
buy a bike again not for profit called
smart commute has optimistically
launched a cycle to work campaign for
Mumbai it's aimed at reducing pollution
and traffic congestion while promoting
exercise but the danger on the roads
isn't the only challenge of Mumbai
sticky climate we need to give good
parking area for the cycles and have
shower rooms because if you prefer if
employee comes in and if he's all sweaty
it just gets a little difficult to curve
for the day India's new generation of
cyclists are under no illusion that the
odds are stacked against them on and off
the road I've still decided that a more
sustainable future is work and
discomfort and the risks